you what dude do you know you should do
is put nacho cheese in the [ __ ] face
bro Brennan thinks he's getting
headaches it's and those are ideas dude
every time somebody asked him a question
I wants an answer from him he takes
ibuprofen he's like I don't know I'm
just joking man I Love You Man sunscreen
huh huh yeah you look like Kimmy Gibbler
getting ready for a vacation
maybe now she's lesbian you know I do
look like that lady from Mary with
children mber her marry or whatever noon
was the neighbor I mean the neighbor you
kind of do she was real hot like the
first couple years and she was still
hottest you got later but she turned a
lot more in a light kind of like a
little more butch exotic bird kind of
look you know exotic butch look yeah
exotic butch like um like she's from
butcher agua you know I feel bad where
we Hey I want to start this off a your
skin you're looking good today dude
looking crispy huh yeah looking crispy
dude did you go on vacation what are you
been doing huh we're we're it where were
you this weekend Wow definitely are you
gonna need help to get out of that
sentence I'll say this dude I was with
the Impractical Jokers
spit it out you ask me what I do I know
right away super suspect well we are
both uniquely ignorant bro pretty
awesome how about when we get I feel bad
because we're getting our coffee it's a
young transgender woman who get makes
our coffee and I hold on who not who
makes our coffee this person works
nearby at an establishment make some
coffee
she makes coffee and we happened upon
the environment yeah correct
I mean it's not like our personal coffee
maker yeah we don't have like
it's a transgender ok email you know AJ
she walks out my girl what's up bro did
you I did I felt so bad what's up bro
and I I pretend I didn't say it and
stared off at this guy I went what's up
bro
or bro Zilla that's what you can turn
that into huh man stuff to come back
from it's not the way you want to kick
off the day but I think a transgender
person would like if I say if you know
if I'm like if I am feeling like 50% man
50% woman you know we're kind of you
know you know in that in that space you
know like that Bermuda Triangle yeah
sure I think if someone calls you bro
that's kind of ok
I don't think so I could tell it hurt
her feelings oh you oh you could tell ok
then that's different is Miriam do they
really smile through the coffee at me
what all right really
no Danny you're dressed insanely very
uniquely today nicely that's what I'm
man thanks dude
someone said of him to mean to you so
yes the word on the street I just I said
you know when he didn't have a
cigarettes he gets me oh definitely what
suck dick and he it's me Wow already
talking about wieners and stuff nope
don't know this absolutely not yeah oh
really
we're gonna do you look like a pastor at
a banana republic dude you look like the
worst Wahlberg brother you look like a
shitty smaller brother they made all the
wrong decisions but they all have to
financially support now out in LA yeah
did I look like trout Wahlberg if you
have any if you have any glass or
reflect our mirrors or anything a
reflective glass you should go buy them
because you look like one of the beagle
boys that [ __ ] came out of the closet
moved to New York bro while the rest of
your family was doing crime like you're
supposed to dude you're like [ __ ]
robbing this dock yeah dude like spiffy
beagle
so sue peels dough yeah oh my god
powerful culture corner over here today
yeah we got some heaters in here today
or what our boys what up what's up Derek
how are you I'm good man how are you
feel I'm doing pretty good what's going
on over there in the black community it
was a well you have a better chance of
knowing then he and I do he lives in a
gated way gated community doctor bridge
yeah and I'm over here in middle in the
little Middle East over here in Los
Angeles
I'm een I live in basically like a
little bit of an extension of the Gaza
Strip Ron so it's uh you know I mean
people are waving flags in the park I
have no idea rocks thrown rocks deal
yeah yeah it's like yeah how do you feel
about this my oh this is already right
back what's going gay oh I thought it
was pretty cool man and also just right
on time you know what I'm saying he's
just perfect timing in there yeah I'm
about coming out yeah just a boost take
itself really maybe to boost him to who
dude
people who what today you know you want
more of a gay fan base I don't know dude
yeah you think
but you think little Naz you feel it was
a good move I mean I mean I'm sure it's
a black people about this I'm making
love to men as well but it's also a good
move for his career you know the main
thing is both of good moves yeah like
he's having a good time the whole way
around good move for his personal life
too you know yeah I mean if he yes also
I think also most people probably knew
that he was gay or preferred men he you
know he just gave off that I wouldn't
yeah I bet he is that kind of like
sometimes to me like a gay some gay men
they have that like they've been kind of
just looking for sugar a little or
something you know I'm saying like their
mouth kind of has like that little
sweetness yes tear that's sweet and low
yeah like they just [ __ ] just
polished off a lemon about eight minutes
ago you know just a lime or straight the
last rib and just you know like that bad
boy dry
yeah and kept it in their pockets maybe
hid it later yeah but yeah but uh proud
of them you know yeah that's awesome but
some of it is it's like when is it like
an opportune time to do it is it PR
stuff but I think at this point and
those guys careers at that level
everything probably has a PR spin behind
it or whatever for sure you could just
keep it to yourself
yeah name the most successful gay rapper
I feel like it's frowned upon in your
community actually I think in poor
neighborhoods if it's black or white
like yeah cuz if I think about it yeah
we had this this fella named Roy boy oh
and he uh yeah and they call him that
when he was nine dude and he was about
six and a half feet tall and four feet
of it was hair you know Roy boy people
he put his hair straight up as high as
it could go in it was a lot of hair did
it look like a little hay bale you know
on his head and he would invite us over
to do play battleship and stuff and play
like water games in the tub and all kind
of stuff yeah not naked but bathing
suits but it was a small tub dude so any
a little sugar and you couldn't help but
really get to know each other you know
it sounds like a nice guy but also he
wasn't nice he was very he he ended up
he was rude and aggressive and he would
beat us if we didn't behave on the ship
you know that was his big though he was
pretty impressed Rick survived yeah he
had more of a domination yeah vibe you
know but yeah I think if he would have
said he was gay in like a poor
neighborhood then people would have been
not cool about it whereas like in poor
black neighborhoods growing up I always
heard like that it was like kind of like
a taboo something it might just be like
in a poor environment it might just be a
low-income yeah
people don't is that fair to say yeah
poor people don't like gay stuff yet why
it's just it's already hard enough
without you know maybe somebody you know
doing like you need you know trying to
teach the guys on the basketball team
like you know I don't know I don't know
without thought I had an idea
yeah let's get started though yes but a
little nos got them hit suit in isn't
the new song is good too what's the new
one with cardi B I haven't heard that
one dude which one were you talking
about it's someone he whenever he came
out of the closet he put this thing on
Twitter as a video with a song yeah the
cartoon where he's like just gone off
into the air I didn't see that I got to
tell y'all looks like a skiddy city
skyline the ones just a big dick is it a
wiener yeah man waynebow wiener well
that's our 7 dude look into it dude I
got deep last night watching all Alex
Nunes and Eddie Bravo talking about
tower 7 dude you went too deep well it's
crazy
bro look into a man it's crazy bro your
house could fall down dude and who did
it
you know I would never do that dude I'm
not driving all the way out there you
went deep into it though huh in there
huh you you believe in all that look man
I think there's definitely at this point
if this meeting people are starting to
think about it then I think there's
there's something going on save this
many people you mean the people that
follow Alex Jones that's not the
majority would disagree
well people call them AJ okay first of
all and I like more Eddie Bravo style
man you know cuz Eddie kind of gets I
and like this has his eyes closed it
just keeps talking about yeah no one's
alright dude the other night the comma
store is Eddie and Sam cornered me
because I said something about [ __ ]
aliens and they went oh yeah it kind of
messed me up for the now I was stuck for
an hour oh it's great that make you
reconsider everything you've ever been
on drugs kinda it really is it yeah yeah
you're like damn unless we're going deep
and cats here too we're multicultural
here yeah so girl what's up cat what's
going on are you celebrating fourth of
July this year I celebrate fourth of
July but it's more so my birthday than
fourth of July major beated it's
tomorrow oh wow
did you get anything huh cupcakes cake
anything yeah I got her something she
doesn't like sweets that much so I got
her something she wouldn't she loves
sweets I know I was just trying to take
a shot in the dark and see if my god
seemed like I knew her better than you
did yeah um I haven't gotten or
something but now I'm gonna I'll
probably eat her a new king in this
thing sure we have search for girls now
we're doing well they're coming
but cata get the first one yep there you
go cat what do you do what are you
celebrating yeah I am gonna head back to
San Jose this weekend to see my parents
oh no you hang out with them my dad's
birthday's also on Saturday damn you
guys like those m-80s or what that works
you can blackcats the hikes means I love
fire what I'm saying your dad make I'm
saying does he what what Dad
what nothing what what Wow Wow
this is when I check out a burning smell
most racist no not today it's a new
record
not today man either way can't have fun
out there happy early birthday cat from
someone who I appreciate it guys are you
doing thing for the fourth when you were
growing up was there fireworks in New
Orleans oh yeah there was fireworks year
round here Sunday was a big firework
night bottle rockets toasters oh dude a
lot of times yeah people we have bottle
rockets were big if you had a freaking
pack of bottle rockets
yeah some yeah share somebody yeah kill
a cat scare senior citizen okay
oh yeah all right turn it up dead or
wietfeldt we drink wine and throw the
bottles off the interstate of our bridge
on the interstate same thing as
firecrackers yeah keep people on their
toes yeah yeah it's more about keeping
people activated in the area yeah it
really is you can't get fireworks
anymore though although someone dear me
yes you can dance in ronita
okay San Bernie toe is a new place that
Brenda made up um I don't know or if
you've been in playing fortnight or
something you never heard of San
Bernadino is that what it is yeah well
there you go
yeah it took you by fireworks out there
December tini oh yeah I was in Texas uh
and you could buy tons of fireworks
there yeah
bring him here the cops are shut you
down well they really yeah they seized
like four million dollars in fireworks
are you serious long bunch of wimps
around here bunch of stray [ __ ] dude
let me pop my brockett's bro Oh bro
these people around here can't even
handle a egg like a regular egg you know
that's not from a chicken that's on
[ __ ] drugs or whatever you do three
to five years for lighting a snake in my
neighborhood really yeah that [ __ ]
snake dude that little thing remember
that thing yeah and it would just keep
climbing out of itself
see I think that's awesome man support
the podcast here's an ad yo do you need
some wine at 4 p.m. maybe some sushi
maybe that breakfast burrito hitter in
the morning oh I want that burrito I got
you a pop bad talking about postmates
it's not me I'm not gonna bring over
postmates swell post mates your personal
food delivery grocery delivery whatever
kind of delivery system you want bro
respect man I love the fact that you eat
food that somebody brings you it's cool
it's cool it's like you have your own
little assistant they just whatever you
want it 24 hours a day 365 days a year
post mates will bring it to you within
an hour and now what kind of stuff can
you get creme brulees can you get yogurt
ice cream burritos Pete's
sushi stainless trauma why not
and for a limited time post mates is
given the king of the sting listeners
$100 a free delivery credit for your
first 7 days to start your free delivery
it's a deal great deal download the app
and use the code cat 2019 that's K 80s
to 0 1 9 that's code cats 2 0 1 9 for
$100 a free delivery credit for your
first 7 days when you download the post
may stack up you can just get fully
stacked up so if you want this you want
that you want a steak you want to arm
thing a life savers you can do it all
anything you need anytime you need it
post mate it download post mates and
save with the code k 80s to 0 1 9 snack
up time to buy few more pants by let's
kick this off shout out to 4th of July
let's start with some debate
up first we got grace this is Grace oh
yeah get them back buzz buzz girl this
one's so easy to me is it really haha
this is easier than crunch your smooth
peanut butter Wow well we also only make
really easy questions coming here no
that's one of us easy here I was I don't
take these I would say Canada all
goddamn day the neighbors to the north
there's no cartel up there and they're
not trying to get into hair there's a
reason today yeah it's nice there dude
yeah a little Eskimo hos everywhere
yeah good food nice people what else
name a couple more things is gonna get
good about Canada yeah they got hockey
okay okay for more things they got nice
they got maple syrup I hear Vancouver
they have Drake they have quite blender
okay JB from Toronto dude Drake is
starting to look like a freaking truck
or bro like a mix lesbian truck or dude
he's getting there he's celebrating a
little too much yeah celebrating well
too much he said too many beef franks it
looks like you can go with Mexico listen
there's a reason jumping the border bro
hmm cartel - bro think about that it's
muy peligroso in Mexico there's too many
you know that's the thing I don't like
if I'm doing cocaine you know I don't
like to be in a hot hot area I like to
be more hydrated Canada you know I think
Mexico here's here's what I think would
help we give a river to Mexico we got a
lot of rivers [ __ ] milling around
here you know the Idaho River the you
name here - there's one yeah name the
other one Mississippi oh you got keep
going huh you going dude mr. rivers my
bad
there's tons of bad your mom made you
study the rivers girl enough brothers
tons of rivers bro Colorado River
Quarry named it yeah CT baby which one
is it you named it
Colorado Mississippi okay okay you're
going we know I am too river shop okay I
do the two mains and I'm out dude the
Okeechobee okay mister making a Native
American names of okay would not be Lord
maybe it's maybe it's Okeechobee dude
it's a Florida River they also have
Table Rock that's a mountain South
Africa it's in Missouri it's a river is
it really yeah how big is it can someone
look it up Table Rock River it's a river
dude
but dude I can say anything and people
have named rivers at the Los Angeles
River how about that nope not a real
river is it nope
yes it is Table Rock Lake in Missouri
which also the outlet goes down a river
up a lake is not just a round river -
you're out of your mind okay the
Tchefuncte River fun I'm starting
historically with our native rivers dude
okay I'm gonna go Hudson okay ah the
Hudson this is in those on a lake Lake
Hudson New Jersey but it's also a river
bro really I remember Hudson River yes
that's a river
he's from New Jersey is it's in
reverence okay so you got one what were
you saying I'll go the Missouri River
very huge River a lot of water in it God
what gave you that the the when I said
Table Rock because that's a Missouri
yeah no [ __ ]
Zuri record oh then there's this very
big in popular river right and that goes
to Table Rock it floats independent one
knows that okay I'll go also with the
Oklahoma River very huge popular outdoor
river
I'm glad you scanned over all the rivers
and came here and that's another popular
river in the North Canadian River and my
friend max has a son named rivers so I
like that name it is a good name
actually I like the name
I forgot it I think get out of your
pants I had it written down
oh wait you know I was great with rivers
can we just say that can we meet
somewhere in the middle what key idea
what's up with Bane's here she wants
some domestic Oh bang ally Canada or
Mexico boys and let me just say first of
all this is a good this is hair coat
ladies if you want a bang
grow them out the front you know that
I'm hangers yeah if you want a bang let
them hang yeah that's it if you got them
bang for the bang you know trying to
bang you let it hot girl no this seems
like a beautiful young woman and I'm
happy she reached out to us what's her
name grace oh yeah right here grace
needs to stay in Canada she is there
because that son would be a real problem
in Mexico for this young white lady
that's true now in Canyon and Mexico
you're gonna get Sun cancer okay you're
gonna get cancer from the Sun in a tank
oh yeah in Mexico in Mexico you can't
wait Kelly ante you're gonna get you're
gonna [ __ ] your pants can't drink the
water you can't drink it it's gonna take
a year to adapt to it because a Kyle
yeah you can't taste the cheese in the
past and down yeah
but also if you get down there to some
nice areas things can be good say Watney
oh where your father lives what's his
name Morgan Morgan State - sorry but if
you guys it was here to get a camera on
there you'll see that he is obviously
Morgan Freeman it's so clear as day no
disrespect to your paper dad but I'm
talking there maybe he's from Morgan
Freeman's from Memphis oh I'm actually
nervous
all those look into it yeah dude you got
thrown a little tower seven over there
Tower say wat nao so that's in Mexico
but yeah can I do look Canada I'm saying
this max Exodus coming to Canada dude a
lot of people are gonna be getting out
of America and moving to Canada I would
go Canada yep friendly people safe
peeping everyone's friendly friendly
people in Mexico - there's just still
too much there's too much
disorganization there there's too much
political unrest there's too much
violence EU get murdered your friend you
take a friend of Tijuana what do you
somebody gets murdered in your group now
you got to find somebody else to be in
your fantasy football league at the last
minute you know and you want to go to
show with your buddies walking the show
it's a donkey show you think it's a
circus adding a circuit yeah that ain't
a circus yeah you got a horn yeah kids
are front row yeah and also sometimes is
it a place you go to like the club's
down there and they're just blasting the
loudest music from like 1994 like
sometimes people want a more peaceful
environment
yeah it's violent Mexico it's just
aggressive and hot sauce doesn't go with
everything you know then so I'm taking
my ass to Canada
but uh break maple syrup end of story
but intent I would like to review this
let's table this and bring it back up in
ten years or four years it's a good
point and see how cuz I think Mexico
could catch up but they gotta tighten
some of that stuff up man I tighten some
stuff he means all stuff and why if it's
greater people leave in there all the
time you know like in their walls it's
just not good advertising it's like if
you want us to come then stay and invite
us what people would go what I would go
more if he wasn't you know always being
like oh I'm getting the [ __ ] out of
there yeah everyone goes there right
everyone
where do Mexico yes no done for vacation
everybody Cancun it's dangerous that
people start elite meeting you know
people go always thinking kun porta
viar-toe what's the other big Natalie
Holloway missing bro you know
oh no say no no yeah
Canada all day 77% of people also went
Canada as well yeah there's no cartel in
Canada baby now I would love it yeah but
listen I say we do deviate
one of these rivers down in Mexico I
think that would help out a lot that's
one thing we're doing is kind of hogging
some of the water throwing a factory
though so it's about Nike from a factory
yes an apple in Mexico yeah throw them a
factory dude light up up I want to pair
those Betsy Ross's that came out you see
that not to see him actually they're
kind of shitty looking fuzzy yeah
captain got pissed about him oh I did
see him with the old school flag in the
back yeah they didn't release those oh
did they look at you looking at shoes
bro they were gonna yeah alright what
else we got up next we got Alex from
Austin Texas oh good this is Alex
powerful hair dude what up Brendan India
this is Alex from Austin Texas and I got
a debate club for you who was better the
Power Rangers or the Ninja Turtles
buzz buzz gang gang gang bruh buzz buzz
dog was too easy for me bro it's too
easy for you yeah then Power Rangers
jumpin them tides all gay and [ __ ]
listen the turtles were that [ __ ] man
the turtles [ __ ] Mike and Angela do you
know all of them you named the turtles
yes I can't go Michelangelo um Donatello
yes that's the tricky one yeah Leonardo
and uh I want to say Oh Fibonacci who is
it right on atella Raphael Michelangelo
Leonardo
Donatello Jesus we are done man and the
last one they all sound the same don't
they Raphael Clara four baby turtles
yeah well I don't like here's ala
obviously you know they got shredder my
dog shredder out there shoutout to
shredder you know and r.i.p a lot of
people no he died a couple months ago
mm-hmm boy the pool man pizza turtles
that's true it's easy bro it's so easy
they originally showed up you know they
got a couple of you know the Power
Rangers it was a gay pride parade I got
all that wood or they got horses in the
back
she and make a rainbow then they're in
tights all of a sudden oh you got the
[ __ ] he was a kid I was like what's
happening right now yeah strange
yeah Power Rangers yeah I didn't know
what they showed up like they yeah it
seemed a little vague you couldn't know
you didn't know who was who
what were they defending yeah no we
don't we know the turtles were defend
they were the sewer and the rat their
master discipline pizza April's fine ass
yeah
the Rat King let's go to the culture
what do you guys think because I think
Brennan is you know all day bro those
guys for sure get [ __ ] Power Rangers
not getting no [ __ ] diversity brother
green the green power is pretty diverse
- it had an asian chick a black dude oh
that's true but you could assume
sometimes could you you can't see any of
them really yeah cat are you a Power
Ranger fan I mean I feel like I have to
be because oh yeah
oh you're younger no that was around the
time I was growing up I weren't there
like a Power Rangers like ninjas or
Samurai some [ __ ] like that yeah I feel
like they just represented more Asian
people so why do you have to be on their
team I could see that kicking jumping
off of stuff electricity coming off of
them that's Asian stuff dude it's like
an anime style kind of moral ninja
there's nothing more Asian than a ninja
yeah Master Splinter was a Asian but did
they train that much or anything like a
lot of times they one of them was lazy I
think Walt relies on him they do drive a
van with Casey and April April 4 1970
pop dude April had them freakin double
tortoise haters on the front yeah dang
bro if you had a bang you
dude I would friggin yeah yellow
jumpsuit remember oh I put on a diaper
and shave my head and pretend I was a
baby dude to get on that tit you know it
so what are the people say shut out the
Turtles Oh 74% ninja turtles so yeah no
[ __ ] speaking power
just what else you who 26% audience who
is obviously cats talkers up next we got
clay from Indianapolis oh yeah I like
you we'll name it for stuff on the
bottom of a river
what up do leper inin this from 19 for
both clay from Indianapolis got a debate
club for you from the cash or card paper
or plastic that Coke hitter or that Coke
chopper Oh your wallet hope you guys are
doing well Gang Gang Macho Man Randy
Savage like that this guy's awesome hey
Dad Gang Gang buzz buzz yeah he sent
this to us from 1987 oh you knew I'm
gonna be here he's an indie might be out
my show in Indiana soon please dressed
like that yes but what do you mean he's
probably deceased now it's from 1987 the
shows get out of hand
skies come from the future you know I'm
saying it's fast you do like the
Terminator bro yeah but the past is 1987
we're not it doesn't go backwards hey
but is he asking if I like cash or
credit yeah just I'm out drugs cash or
credit like at the store oh come on bro
listen I'm more of a cash guy I'm
old-school
I like having cash yeah are you a cash
hitter I like having cash dude make it
rain with credit cards yeah if you can
if you throw your credit card or
stripper but they will accept it I'll
tell you to swipe them cheese yeah you
feel me
yeah dude wipe cheese trying to make a
ring hi cheese yeah I feel you give him
pinkeye brother
sounds dangerous brother it's my middle
name Doug you're a cash cow though yeah
I like cash man I like to have a little
cash hidden around and stuff like that
you know in cases of you know in case
you get somebody kidnapped or whatever
you could pay them right there you get
kidnapped you could pay them right there
I'm not driving off today Tim that's
where you get murdered by kidnappers I
like to pay right up front if I get
kidnapped I feel I like a little cash
also is there anything more embarrassing
when you valet a car some [ __ ] and you
don't have cash a tip the dude
I go I'll get you next time
knowing damn well it's my could be for a
long time and you'll forget for sure
and he'll forget no he won't right row
won't forget you're right and that's
crazy it's also really yeah you can't
really tip people anymore because like
that's the community too it's like
that's a harder working environment you
know people are doing jobs and need tips
you can't even tip oh no now tips if
everything's card you just tip them with
advice you think it's cool
comb your hair you didn't even do that
go to school school TV doesn't care a
lot of different schools bro adult
schools adult college you're crazy boy
you can name more rivers than me they'll
give you that you tell your mom I said
Congrats bro if we had a match bro you
did a good job on the rivers if we had a
map contest I'd smoke you
okay I'm going cash baby I'm doing it
look I don't even care if you cut the
cocaine up dude no there's a block of
ice baby dude yeah
I'll put it at dude I'll hotter look you
know I'll throw a gram in my be whole
bar on that rear jaw you feel me
let's go daddy I'll put that devil brick
in my anus horses in the bag dude
white horses I bet you'd let a couple
dark horses park there
dude I will call the cops there's a lot
of footage you reaching over here let's
do this moving I can't get weird in Chia
huh you're the one that took it weird
there dude hear people booing horse is
in the bag it's all different now I
still like it though 58% went with cash
as well yeah yeah yeah she's gangster in
it huh cash is just more real yeah
credit that you know if the bit did they
unplug it all you got nothing
credit feels fake it's not them what
they unplug it you got nothing man
you're right dude you got nothing baby
just zip your [ __ ] yeah and were you
gonna go who you gonna go knock on the
bank here you can complain to Carl at
the bank that [ __ ] gon bring us
Bank don't give a [ __ ] about your dreams
yeah cash it out man guess it's about to
get heated I say cash it out yep I'm
starting cash in your backyard
yeah time to pay the bills what's up bro
those are good dude thank you bro you
know you look like double-o Schaub
thanks bro double o 12 you shouldn't
have to choose between overpriced
designer sunglasses and cheap shades
dude
yeah if cheap ones won't last they never
do you lose them they fall apart oh yeah
someone take some or what if somebody a
raccoon runs off with him even you could
happen dude it could happen the LOS
angeles-based accessories brand I'm
talking about movement
yeah movement as the best sunglasses
they look dope constructive durable
lightweight materials for the perfect
rival fit look at me brah
oh they get me ready for that summer hit
her oh you definitely look like a guy
that's not gonna pay his parking meter
but you look swaggy dude I'll say that
that's all I want and they have free
shipping and free returns that's their
policy so you can try on as many styles
as you want right from home em VMT they
make watches and they now have
sunglasses yeah and this is what the
cool thing all their lens are Pole
arrives right back in there you're like
are they polarized yeah movement
sunglasses are and they start at 60
bucks no pairs over ninety five dollars
show you guaranteed
find the style you love with quality
that doesn't break the bank yep you can
see far you can see the North Pole even
I see everything you're 15% off today
with free shipping free returns by going
to nvm t.com slash cats let's see why
movement keeps on keepin on check out
their expanding collection go to nvm
t.com slash cats yep get them uh
sunglasses and join the movement
someone's got to pay for Brennan's
coffee habit you guys might be a little
for my heart [ __ ] yeah yeah let's see
some hotties there I can't deal with
this
I'll keep FN lures pop my uncle at a
little bro right uncle slick Victor hey
ba so this is a regular picture of a
dude fishing that's just a nice guy
fishin know he caught that with his
hands dude and he's a freakin Native
American no mo
he's an Eskimo yeah they call him ski
Moe's bro yeah did you have fall down
that fish candy 50 years old he likes to
fish and do crossword puzzles when he's
in this vape he's also a retired
stripper who now just has a warehouse
job been in his younger days ease the
stress speaking of cash oh he's a Native
American dude I mean you basically just
described every Native American nomad
let me guess he drinks alcohol as well a
lake behind him view that's gin vodka
full of vodka
no man victory you seem like a swell guy
man and hand caught fish I love that you
could tell he's not mistreating the fish
a lot of guys they they get the fish and
they throw it in a little ice cool or
something I don't know why Sandro I
think you're off them the mess composure
- [ __ ] - these fish it's gonna eat that
thing face-first soon as the Cameron
looked away boy he might eat it like
that but he's gonna look at in the eyes
for you - not like other people that
sneak up behind it and skin it what I'm
saying is this dude is that male or
female that fish can we zoom in on it a
little I'm gonna go with male but we
don't know now do you catch that thing
with his hands attorneys [ __ ] he catch
that thing with a with a pole of fish
and polar's hands his hands are dirty
from Miss Manners holes bro from years
of hard work Rojo
dude he's a stripper on a pole yeah they
dude you have to be how is she gonna
make any money dude
drinking you can't make any money just
drink don't they make eye sees I don't
think so
that's Hawaiians wow you're right you're
right dude again shut up to your mom
beautiful guy and he used to strip as
well I wonder what led him into that
does it say anything else about him no
that's all we know
good for him a little Magic Mike Eskimo
vibe there yeah
what do you guys think of this guy since
he looks magic Veet door he looks like a
neat man like a guy who's he looks kind
of like that guy um who's the guy that
hides in the woods with football players
and stuff hides in the woods with
football players you know I'm talking
about um and he puts on me some more
description there and he who touch him
you can talk I mean a year you could
touch him if you meet him I'd never met
him
hi did the woods with yes dude with uh
come on Lina
Leonard uh who's that running back that
played for Seattle
yes he hides with people in the woods
Bear Grylls had something enough oh he
looks like Bear Grylls kinda Wow yeah
yeah no I don't think so
no not any faster zoom in a little bit
definitely look in their eyes and ask
him oh I mean it why he's a stripper too
huh
would you watch this guy strip you think
I'll watch [ __ ] I don't know where to
slap that Derek what do you know if I'm
being racist or he's just he just seems
so short he's like 5-1 this guy you want
a tall strip but I got a I need some
lift man I need some body you know I'm
with you man
no one likes to watch small people do we
no one likes small fighters don't like
small strippers don't like small
basketball small football yeah I want so
I'm with do I need some length I need
that [ __ ] anaconda in my face oh my
god bro somebody call Carl Lentz ronita
pastor man I need the Lord if I'm gonna
sit here anymore
you need that anaconda in your face
yours you're nuts guy dude
dong Tama if I was at a strip club and
that was my thing with Dee I need some
light how did we get here this is a man
with a fish I hate Harper with a fish
yeah you're right there's a nice young
gentleman is he though this looks like a
bait and switch literally he's out here
he's showing us the fish but really he
probably even have any ass on this
shorts he probably has he asked cutout
of him
you know what he's a catfish yeah he's a
catfish a catfish and what's he doing
now he's in witness protection they said
they'd say anything I was just working
in the warehouse now oh that's witness
protection okay first of all for sure
working at a warehouse - okay be more
general yeah Victor the stripper
fishermen a lot of Leno is buying this
[ __ ] yeah a lot of left and right turns
in this story so I think that uh yeah
Victor is a I think Victor's a nice
young uncle yeah we just don't know who
he really is no I think he's lying about
everything and he's a catfish have I've
ever seen one yep so flaunt my uncle
what was it pop my uncle pop my uncle
what we call the uncles on this did this
did we change the whole idea behind this
show while I was out of town when I was
well you're what daydream you know where
you're at right now I think I was in
freakin smoke Lahoma dude what else we
got
Oh two guys in Oklahoma said that
they're upset with you about something I
remember what it was but that's all they
said dang I wish you knew I know I'll
try to get more information but I think
the guy was drunk that's fair so I was
like all right I'll tell him that
well shout out to Oklahoma yeah what
else you got D hold on one second boys
horses in the back [ __ ] in the
[Music]
there's not that many [ __ ] in the
front apparently yes really
that's just horses in the back yeah got
in the back like the Alamo really that
he's thinking about yeah yeah
interesting party had one kind of catchy
we got sherry and her partner aunt
Randy oh I'm not mad at these anton aunt
and mrs. flowers in the front flowers in
the back in the trees how do you live
across street from some beautiful
lesbians dude white people on earth
aren't they well i don't know about that
but one of them worked at the library i
remember that and uh and yeah they were
cool they were a little bit violent
sometimes though with each other they
loved to put up Christmas decorations
yeah they can always bake can't they I
mean they cos they could stare a [ __ ]
batter into a damn brownie brother
lesbians can get pretty damn agressive
cool powers men less power
sure well it just depends you had
different types of you know lesbian
women I would be it's me is there's
something that's angry against man for
no reason like you know that kind of
stuff kind of gets on my nerves they
think it's a competition you know it's
weird to me is when you got like one I
think they call them lipstick lesbians
wench it's just this died me dime right
who likes women but then she's dating a
butch girl that like oh yeah she's get a
dude baby yeah but they don't want to do
because dudes well here's the thing a
lot butch lesbian women are the most
covert men you've ever met in your life
bro they're like the swaggiest man ever
they got a lot of testosterone well they
know exactly what to say to a woman
they're basically they're good they're
like Neil Strauss is wherever that guy
that wrote the book that picking up
women you know I know they're like Mel
Gibson what women want
yes but lesbians yeah they're so swaggy
dude and they're beating us at our own
game of chasing women but
competition in it yeah yeah and of
course they're gonna tell chicks don't
go by man you know because they want the
chicks they're tricking us
I think whatever dumb pissed I can pay
you're so right dude yeah mine cuz I
don't know what I'm talking about but
you're right right I don't think so man
I think you're right you're out of your
mind bro I guess dude dude how can you
see I'm right if I don't know what I'm
talking about that means you're crazy
I'm crazy you look like a butch leg so
it's all good
oh definitely now if we're talking to
hair style and t-shirt size yeah dude
these are my people bro that's your
community now look wait what are these
[ __ ] lob their pups we're gonna try
to rein stupid dogs now how about a safe
dog lady could there be any safer dog
than golden retrievers oh yeah
they want more pets first of all what
they want can I chill are we sure these
are lesbians we don't know what
information do we have on these well we
know they're partners okay there are
many business partners is to say that
they have an LLC or their own a
corporation I don't think so do you
think partners in life I think so I
think they own a ring yeah this is
marriage
mmm you think having a ring yeah for
marriage yeah and then they also are
owners of multiple doggy daycares in New
Jersey
oh and now that's another thing man
lesbians lesbian women can take care of
pets better than anyone I grew with that
and that's a superpower man as much
affection and stuff to be able to take
care of animals birds to do this rare
you catch a decent lesbian woman without
a bird or a parrot letter something at
the house yeah well-maintained parakeet
or some [ __ ]
yeah and that's man these partners look
these lesbians are boring you know I'm
saying look super boring like they go to
Bed Bath Beyond on the weekend you know
it just doesn't look like a fun time the
backgrounds annoying me for whatever
reason I don't know this whole thing
just I don't know I don't know dude well
first of all they have a black dog which
i think is you know
for them it's a big step I think even in
that community good point
they have Christmas decorations so
there's celebratory you know I think
they learn haircut well here's the thing
you can't look just look at them as like
two cool dudes that also have four dogs
and do gaming no that's the thing if you
look at them as straight dudes like oh
look at these straight ass dude well
then that's a cool picture yeah yeah
it's two dudes with four dogs and when I
was a vast time don't ya right about
that dude a hundred percent man look at
the glasshouse half full yeah bro you
got a look at the yeah you got a look at
this decently shout out to both these
auntie's yeah and what is it what is it
safe for is this for for my aunt yes sir
whose aunt is it we don't know who's on
a bunch of people what they definitely
know him that you guys just submit this
pig from the mall
yeah you know this is a high quality
there's no system of checks and balances
here is this CNN what is going on here
let's get D o up next we got Uncle Eddie
Don flop Maya
yeah what's last one for fun ah oh yeah
damn Eddie what do you think about this
guy cat what's your first thought when
this you see a man like this in America
oh don't give her any ideas Brendan let
her talk
I think of the movie the revenant mmm an
outdoorsy man can take care of himself
maybe other people very well
no one knows he has the biggest glove in
the world yeah oh and he's in a
snowstorm but he's snow Jay Simpson Brad
look at this dude bro that's the biggest
glove I've ever seen the biggest man
yeah definitely will fit and we can't
acquit you know I'm saying yeah dude
this is it'll suck the liver right out
of Annie Muse but there's this [ __ ]
arm-wrestle moose no problem
yeah this guy definitely has a couple
missing wives or missing little Cubs cuz
he's a big old bear if you yeah
he's out there on his own some Brokeback
revenant that's the vibe I get yeah I
don't know if he seems a very homoerotic
to me man but also if you're out in the
wolf snow dude you by yourself yeah
dude does he bench 700 pounds he's huge
where you'll [ __ ] a warm wall if you're
out in the snow for a long time I didn't
get out there too long yeah if you've
been out there a week dude what's his
name her Uncle Eddie Eddie shout-out to
Edward and do we know any other
information about him oh yeah we uh he's
the biggest redneck you'll ever meet
apparently mmm
he worked at a truck stop for years
keeping a lot lizards under control and
now I was just in that killing animals
and sometimes he actually kills them
with his bare hands I buy all of that I
love that I believe all that and does it
say anything else that he likes to do
does he read or does he do you know you
see what his favorite show favorite
shows are me too I'd be very interested
to see what his favorite shows are any
guesses Wonder Years I bet you're going
Wonder Years
would you do everyone said the the best
friend off there was Marilyn Manson for
a hot second it's not though that's when
the internet started dude that's what
started the internet really and you're
the other rumor Marilyn Manson removed a
rib he had to blow himself then he
started that I bet you went there I was
just saying he removed a rib yeah yeah I
heard he removed you really made a spoon
out of a tough soup I believe that yeah
I believe it dude shout to this giant
uncle you think do you think if somebody
took one of your ribs out of your body
and put it in a lineup with other bones
or other ribs you'd be able to know your
rib from others I'm not a rib expert but
what if you touched each rib would you
know you think which one is yours it'd
they now I'm saying they put you to
sleep they take a rib out of your body
sure okay they chopped a rib out then
put it next some baby back ribs no
put it know you're gonna notice if it's
like in a in a rack of ribs look we're
not it's in a rack of ribs no is it
covered in st. Louis barbecue sauce or
we talked in south southern barbecue
sauce
I feel like this dude I feel like this
wilderness guy when I get into a
conversation with you dude I feel like
I'm in the wilderness go and I [ __ ]
we're running out of water and it's
getting late and say they took ribs out
of other people out of sense out of six
other people and they said although each
one of those ribs in front of you if you
touch the rib do you think you would get
a sense of which one was your know do
you I think you would probably healthy
you think you'd get whether they tell
the pain like sometimes when soldiers or
people like a shark bites off an arm Oh
shark say not sympathy pains they had a
phantom right like it still feels like
you're on phantom dude from my Marvel
Universe whatever the opera's I think
let's go on my bro
your brain is like a damn blender dude
punch it just [ __ ] man up next we got a
little [ __ ] smoothie in there hey we
need you to a cigarette or somebody's
dick Wow
dick jokes huh funny still alright the a
man Thank You Derek for being at least
trying to be respectful to everyone I'm
trying to we got some relationship
advice this is Angela from Spring
Oklahoma oh she sounds beautiful just
snakes in the front in the back my guy
that I was with for two years
your robot we just recently broke up Oh
constantly cheated oh he's not the only
one
every guy before him that I've been with
has felt the need to wander off yeah
doesn't matter what I do keeping up with
the house making sure foods on the table
keeping up with my cells the night
please come back hold on it's sorry
Brendan wants to starve at home
obviously the start over let's go back
to the middle this lady on the table
house is spotless I don't see much when
he walks she's just holding the male
she's like tell me what it says
I don't educate myself housewife this is
what she likes to do be at home do
recipes take care of the house take care
of the kids
[Laughter]
like I'm gonna Dave and Busters and the
powers out brother
[Laughter]
still playing all the game you still
kicking the ticket machine wonder why
the tickets aren't coming out who cares
take 70,000 tickets to get a damn
whistle you idiot all right let's let
this poor lady finish okay I don't what
I do
keeping up with myself making sure
things say exciting role playing in the
bedroom do you know but they always come
back that's the thing oh oh so I'm just
wondering what makes them wanna wander
in the first place tell me something
good gang gang buzz buzz buzz my
housewife
I think he said buzz bust I think of you
that buzz he on the end of it oh you
broke me used to are Desmond after you
condemn this lady's lifestyle I'd love
to see how you gonna dig yourself out of
shovels in the front do dig yourself out
of this [ __ ] you put yourself in
Devils in the front
shovels in the bag man they always come
back I don't know man maybe they take
her for granted and they're just not
trying to [ __ ] with or maybe she's just
too good that I got she might be
overwhelming
it's not that she'll have her own [ __ ]
going on get a hobby get less tattoos
you know I'm saying well you don't like
it I guess - is Brendan you will all do
that it will just stop getting him maybe
although I think they're sexy
okay then while you say that Dan she is
from a spring Oklahoma who sprung out
there doing that Brokeback [ __ ] and then
come back after the up to those storm
well that's saying no that's not even a
good idea I don't think but what I will
say is this and I'm sorry it's a good
idea but I just don't think that that's
accurate what I'm thinking is if these
guys are leaving well maybe y'all have
too many doors on your house or
apartment you know time I've taken
people prisoner know if people can get
out easily don't think I'm prisoner but
don't put four doors on your house but
here's Nathan be upset if your spouse
leaves they can [ __ ] get out he's
confused yeah you're one door I don't
even do a back door you come in the
front you go out the front one door
doing was in the front doors in the
front
we're making so many goddamn pies sounds
like she's cooking all the time maybe
it's overwhelming for the dude maybe you
need to mix it up start going out on him
we're making apple pies cherry pies
rhubarb pecan pumpkin hahaha
one pie a week one pie a week Netflix
and chill she seems like an older soul
does she nope do you
no you are just a real strange guy man
come on bro don't touch me do not talk
let me do touching the hot look I think
maybe I don't know what do you guys
think
let's go to cab maybe let's get a one
perspective let's also talk to Derrick
as well you know oh yeah dude I mean
definitely she's providing way too much
to these guys yeah do that especially
when you're younger they get too
comfortable start taking you for granted
do your hold is she caps right how old
is she yeah if you're 19 homeboys coming
on you got a seven-course meal you
dressed like a 50s housewife and he got
[ __ ] you know yet you hold it you
you're doing too much you're scaring
everybody away it sounds like yeah
you're just going out the alley and one
of those seven doors you have in your
house yeah I'm a little fun evey yeah
maybe uh yeah I don't know okay she may
be chasing guys who just aren't ready to
settle down the same way she is - she's
hot yeah that's true he's young maybe
she's ready for something that younger
guys around her age aren't ready for
older soul exactly do you what do you
think I think she definitely hooks up
with a lot of dudes who attract a lot of
girls so stop that [ __ ] a Seth Rogen
looking [ __ ] yeah who's gonna be
grateful Betty's look at you you know
what I mean and I bet that problems done
and then if that guy cheats on you then
it's definitely you you know what I mean
read a book or something you think it
get ugly dude Shades of Grey I'm sure
you're [ __ ] the same guy over and
over again and that's why they keep
cheating you talking about that bad boy
a hitter dad boy here well doesn't that
pipe game yeah there's a whole spectrum
to you if you get a guy that's all about
looks or something like that thing you
might you know you know it might not get
a guy that as much harder as much like
you know gratitude or anything like that
so you got to kind of even the scale out
it's like if you get a 10 and looks then
they're gonna be a seven and some you
know it's all it's all relative it's all
evens out you know you want that's why
you want to get that eight you want to
find an eight the hard a that harder
they don't go for the 10 [ __ ] boy yeah
they're down eight Tianna day get that
eight yeah date an eight day mate
because everybody can be an eight here's
the thing every
can be 1/8 if they take care of themself
that but I like read I liked how
positive you are in 8 and 8 you know I'm
saying anybody can be a 5 put in 8 know
if you brush your teeth and you and you
I think have you know a little bit of
insight right yes I'm self-awareness
address will be innate I think AHA she
can be as a 6 damn yeah God doesn't give
anyone good looks bro trust me I know
dude I know you know okay but look what
you've done with your stuff dude I'm
cross-eyed but both of them are in the
st. they're both the straight cross yeah
yeah you like a chameleon yes crossed on
the inside on the outside it looks fine
shut up to this thing I hope she figures
out quit [ __ ] with him [ __ ] boys oh
that's the problem well I don't know if
we didn't help that woman I feel like we
did though well how about a little rip
my dripping fellows yeah yeah let's rip
him up a surprising feeling you got
first we got Nigel and his girlfriend
Leon how do you pronounce that word
Nigel okay and then Tiana just saying I
don't anybody sending in something
racist to us oh dang yeah it looks like
Jay : Nicki Minaj made every wrong
decision uh boy I like you know what I
like I like how they were in the same
color I like how he's obviously in white
pants when this isn't even a racist
thing but I feel like only black guys
can pull off white pants not a lot of
white dudes pulling off white pants
Latin or black white guys I don't know
the Mark Twain that's a thing back then
though Mark Twain what about um Oh Don
Johnson Don Johnson Mark Twain also that
guy who had the megaphone in WWE and WF
Bret the mouth of the South Jimmy Hart
was at him no mouth of the south you
guys know the mouth of the south is if
you have white pants on though but yeah
Jim well there's some exceptions but in
general why did you stay away from white
pants
yeah so but yeah a black guy or a mixed
guy I got with some tint and a skin can
look better in lighter colors because
you can sauce the grass you can wear
white pants yeah that's my rule so we
would they want to flaunt that on huh oh
then what that drip rim Oh rip that drip
yeah yeah I like the match he match II I
think it's kind of like because then you
know you
a team unless you out there fight and if
I see a couple and matching [ __ ] that's
fight nothing worse oh she got them
horses in the front oh yeah she got the
milk horses in the front dude horses in
the front camels in the back dairy
ponies parked on the fricken on the
Ponderosa but no they both look I can't
some people there yeah couple man he's
got that Rastafarian vibe coming in a
little longer and he's not gonna
probably he's gonna have trouble
probably getting employed except unless
he's you know smelling that reefer
selling reef or doing boating or doing
fishing also dreads tend to smell like
Dookie oh there's a length at a certain
point I think he's still in a safe zone
he's in a cold zone yeah yeah but if you
go any longer
dude you're a cold thing worse than a
long yeah you don't say no you can snip
one off and smoke it Dave you know well
if you to cut off part of a dreadlock
and plant it dude a stuffed [ __ ] rose
yeah they did that in our school when I
was a kid
that makes sense dude white people with
dreads name something worse to go
doesn't exist I like these two I'd like
to see a jheri curl come back on this
beautiful gentleman right here I think
he could do it like you and a jheri curl
I can't do it
oh we could back into turn well we keep
an S curl in your hair I don't think we
can man we don't know Derek D D what do
you we shoot someone D they get that
jheri curl bro look yeah do it bro yeah
that should be dope well here's the
thing I nobody has one I'm in tan never
got miles that works at the Laugh
Factory and he's got real kind of curly
hair you know I'm talking about and he
I've all got been telling him to grow in
for a while there are ours is suggesting
to him dude have you ever seen a black
dude with the S Curl mullet Leffew
mullet it up a little bit S Curl hair
and then shave the side do when I when I
was young you had a lot of Gary curls
and I loved him I loved him you had one
eazy-e bo Jackson D even have have one
for a little bit for a little bit
hot SEC younger yeah yeah yeah Santa's
hat down wet Wow
Oh bro dude he used to keep a cup on his
shoulder and just dripping the real
beautiful dude
poor riding on his [ __ ] car and
cruise off yeah praise God beautiful all
right
you had that matchy-matchy it's a risky
move doe if y'all enough fighting in the
street bro that [ __ ] doesn't you know
also what's behind them though what is
that time I've ever seen mirrors like
that are at a they're on a vacation on a
cruise yep on decay in the Bahamas on a
who thought it looked weird
it's a Natalie Holloway gift set right
there in the sink they got a couple
snorkel snorkel masks that Titanic
fashion I'm not mad at him yeah shut up
the lovely couple looking black she's a
dime a dime what else we got mm-hmm up
next we got this is young chap from
Baltimore chat young chat down so this
dude I think is Jewish maybe did ice
take this picture what's going on it's
covered in five g's of kratom straight
from Tyler oh yeah don't let you in see
they said he sent this one in 4chan
this guy's British I think is that mr.
bean son dude that's that kratom hitter
right Baltimore man yeah which is Donny
is his name is nick young chap yeah yeah
I bet he snorts all that kratom just
writes the meanest blog on the Internet
definitely looks like how much kratom
Zen is he got two different colors
yeah he's that's that deep kratom dive
then kratom guys you were [ __ ] with the
kratom uh-uh
I've seen you know there's been some
videos of chin having
Jenna doing just starts singing yeah
snorts and just starts singing like a
country-western can you snort it you can
do anything with it they'll dude I
snorted some vitamin-b one time and uh
like I tell it like a TV thing they were
shooting pretty cool it's like fake
cocaine you can do as much as you want
oh that's what they put right yeah for
the white powder yeah it's really cool
you just keep doing it weird
shout to this kratom King though that's
the kratom King
brah this young chap dude I feel he
apparently sent you some Michels granola
a few weeks back don't even II wonder
what you thought don't eat that food
I've not opened that yet um but as soon
as I do I'll eat it bro maybe or he
[ __ ] doused and covered it and kratom
oh you do have no you have no dude you
sent him granola send your boys from
Crate I'm not like Theon a [ __ ] I'll
take it hey kratom King I used it
everyday maybe you can handle a hey
kratom King what else we got thank you
young chap I haven't eaten the brownies
yet it's granola bro yeah it will be
well if it was brownies it'll definitely
be granola lot of time I open it because
but thank you for sending a man as sweet
of you bro and I'll have some of it
sweet good luck out there dude obviously
you're gonna get busted for something do
good luck slanging that kratom on the
streets of bolt actually way good luck
if you've been a baltimore but yeah
that's what I'm saying the wire yeah bro
Baltimore Ravens got Robin their squad
tweets got Ray Lewis who killed a dude
up well the wire and a lot of people
that are untethered if you want to see
some outtakes from The Walking Dead go
to downtown Baltimore dude a lot of
people brought arms in the front zombies
in the bag World War Z ok I'm an
worthless rapper that was some King
understand this first one is Jake pass
from Christian Mississippi Jay knows
Jake from past Christian man I'm sorry
no you're not me very wise amen very
wise chin and Nick now who knows bro
together we don't know jury's out juries
and if you mix their names together you
know what their nickname is I don't
let's go
here we go what's up Brendon going on DL
Jake from Pass Christian Mississippi
I got a king and stinger for you guys
real quick though rip my long rip my lon
Loni shout to Lonnie who actually talks
like a Jason Momoa style badass what do
you think okay you know it's kind of
gangster with it dude
if you're looking for a lady just bust
that thing out at a park and start
slinging them the girls freaking tits in
the front cheeks out the back you start
throwing them hammers dude they dig it
Thor's in right now it's a big it's a
ballsy move dude do another Park get
arrested snort some kratom get a girl
yeah go ahead dill stitches in the
sternum bro it looks dangerous dude
throwing axes but you know what I'm
saying
the paid treat one of my favorite felons
probably one of the top 40 or 25 films
ever aim small miss small man dude
Apocalypto you're seeing them bad boy
hitters the original hitters know things
blue people those avatar same movie but
with Native Americans I don't [ __ ] with
these blue lions I think well these were
Reds they were yeah Redskins that's not
racist term that's a Washington Redskins
term mm-hmm I don't care man either way
you ever thrown a [ __ ] blade like
that yeah it's hard to do it's not that
hard to do bro you can throw I'm saying
it's hard to make it stick like homeboy
did here with this shout-out to his lawn
I'm not mad that long at all Oh brah
[ __ ] I'll take the Lisp off of a
troubled boy bruh I could throw that ax
easily I think ya circumcised a few kids
oh dude I could circumcise a squirrel
from 60 paces damn I didn't know you had
that skill yeah it's tough like I've
tried throwing it stuff it's actually
very what's tough about it throwing a
light axe at a board to get to stick
though bro not that tough dude if you
know what you're doing no wow
shout-out to Apocalypto what disguise
him again Donnie Jake Jake close and
what was this question for one accident
accidents just in general yeah this is
the Tomahawks people always doing in
their backyard
the only tomahawk I like is my steak
yeah I'm not trying to go back in time
to throw axes I say front yard it man
I say it's time to take things from the
backyard into the front yard the best
idea you've ever had all directions in
the front you know because here's a
thing you want the neighbors to know you
want that guy that's thing about
stealing your car battery to know the
skill set you have you want the guy who
borrowed your mower three months ago to
know suddenly it's time to wash that
[ __ ] and bring it back and turn it
mother [ __ ] yeah it's time to hit the
pawn shop and get that [ __ ] back and
bring it back to you is do yeah well I
say eight idea bro yeah I say you put
these uh you put the yeah you put this
thing in the front and show the neighbor
who's boss set up front man become the
bat man in the neighborhood yes don't
start with this ninja stars do something
else
make sure no it's [ __ ] flaming bow
and arrows sharp spoons firecrackers yes
dude spoons bro we speed off of the
sharpest spoons when I was young not
these wussy ass spoons with the
comfortable edges I'm talking about a
shank no we had the sharpest spoons
around bro you two just barely get that
soup off a tear oh dude you know I don't
like his ass only give me a sport the
other day they did yeah get the [ __ ] out
of my face also paper straws I also get
on my face yeah the turtles gonna run
into a [ __ ] astrology deserves it you
know I'm saying yeah that's what I'm
saying dude well they said their thing
about outlaw and forks in Los Angeles
because in Hollywood cuz they said it's
too just offensive to the food on the
plate I'm with this dude I'm with the
old best idea all day bring that [ __ ] to
the front flex on the neighbors yeah do
last time bro become the man you've
always wanted to be bro start riding a
horse in the front shirt off bro get a
pony dude you know what I'm saying throw
an axe bro do get a crocodile yeah
it's fourth of July man do whatever you
want to do son it's America baby
yo what else you got you got another one
here from Erin Sheppard from Grand
Rapids Michigan
Erin Sheppard okay welcome to Maya King
interesting it attention
tapping [ __ ] whispering in your gear
crumbling things slurping noodles
[ __ ] crunching on ice chunks what do
you guys think does it make you feel so
relaxed more like you have a lot of
anxiety what are you getting an idea I
have a huge erection but I'm also upset
those day old chips oh it's a real pet
peeve of mine bro but have a condition I
forget what's called dak Shepherd called
it out he has the same condition I
forget what's called legit condition I
can't listen to people chew food like
crunchy food yeah I'm telling you man my
girl loves slinging hot cheetos if she
starts eating them I have to go upstairs
I can't hear any of it if the fan is on
if people are slurping dream size it's a
condition I'm talking you want to see me
go zero to 100 eat some chips around me
bro see what happened it's not my
ability that way since I was a kid
what about ruffles you think can't do
with ruffles Fritos Doritos nachos
burritos are loud can we do you know how
making these loud ass [ __ ] I'm saying
sog them up a little bit but also I went
to a movie when those movie theaters we
can like order dinner and [ __ ] and just
eat dinner at home and watch the [ __ ]
movie but you can order meal oh yeah I'm
[ __ ] prick next to me some lesbo oh
yeah butch girl ordered the vegetable
tray oh snapping on carrots cauliflower
broccoli
I believe the movie I missed the movie I
think get up and leave my girl stay and
watch why I went outside that's how bad
my condition is dude it's a real medical
condition no it is not I promised you oh
just because you and Dax Shepard decided
it was I guess because y'all are sound
[ __ ] here's Ronson
the world is filled with sounds bro okay
Lauren sounds trigger me bro well then
go talk to a specialist dude I do talk
to a free delayed delivery guy or
somebody who deals with this [ __ ]
regular you know don't be crying outside
of the damn
you know cinema 17 yeah because you
can't handle it you don't have any tips
or conditions deal I mean I'll tell you
this dude I have this uncanny ability
that I hate it's like it's almost like
my superpower if I go into a restroom I
can tell like almost to the second when
the last time somebody took a dump in
there that's a cool superpower they time
hot bro it's miserable
oh it's miserable right in a walk-in oh
my god Oh 42 seconds it's not a cool
power it's the worst so but I deal with
that you know I prepare myself a little
bit for I go in the restroom you know I
throw a couple crazy times in my head
I'll just say like 2 minutes and 9
seconds 40 minutes yeah 10 seconds you
know so that way when I go in my mind is
like you know kind of yeah it's just
kind of focusing on other stuff but yeah
dude if you can't help somebody chewing
cheese I'm telling you it's a real metal
couldn't condition then you're gonna die
when the world comes yeah why me if
aliens start chewing on [ __ ] yeah or if
your neighbor does bro somebody cracks
up when I can't have [ __ ] baby
carrots and you're done daddy came over
day I came over so loud though it's
ridiculous dude I was off a bit Kenny
the other day grabbing a coffee I had to
pee so bad there's someone in the
bathroom right and there's like a long
line I'm next up someone's in there for
a hot I mean I'm I'm 8 minutes long time
dude this dimepiece dumper comes out she
knows she blew it up she come down just
like this and walked right by she winked
at you dude and she blew that bathroom
up maybe she had something right did she
look like she could have had something
wrong nope it was just like you ain't
gonna do [ __ ] wank damn super-sexy wow
man that's feminism dude the dumper
dimepiece shout-out to her if she's out
there she's not out there man if she's
out there and you want to get to feel
you gotta get through the B
that's not how you say it and she's not
out there man it might have been a dude
okay well story changes quick dude Anna
come in the front steam
Oh is she saying it's a bad thing yeah
what's he she knows she might have the
same condition cuz she went through all
the the triggers for people who have
this like chomping on those chips
everything so she might have it so I
don't know the qinger sting is she's
saying G has it - yes she's saying ASMR
do you like it there's these videos out
there on the internet where people are
touching things and you know and they're
just and they're ignorant or whatever
and seeing it it's like a thing ASMR
I've never seen so much something in my
life that [ __ ] bothers me I like it but
I don't like the ones of the famous what
people doing it because then I feel like
they start to book on it it's like it
gets a little ego II sometimes you know
like yeah like there was this one kind
of hottie doing it and then she started
to seem like a real [ __ ] by the time
she had like her mm sound or something
you know and I'm like look anybody can
make a damn sound you know it's not like
you're Mozart it's not a skill yeah but
also another little fact about me that
most people don't know I don't like my
hands wet either that also I'm a weird
kid dude you can't do drugs I can't do
carrots or get my hands wet big Nos they
call them big Nos what else do we got
that's it boys dang that's it we've had
a lot about each other did we feel like
that's true feel like it dude yeah
what's the breakdown from it I learned
about you that sounds hands wet sounds
hands wet you don't like kind of a
housewife kind of lady no I do I just
think that's that she's coming on too
strong for the fellas in Oklahoma yeah
we also learned you know little nas
little nas is out on a whole new but we
was he gonna start dating what get what
do you think Tyler the Creator Jaden
Smith I bet none of the creators gay or
not gay oh he is well he's Bobby's
Bobby's definitely nice damn it yeah
yeah yeah dudes that were like man that
what time we got all drunk college and
suck dick oh no
gay girls can do that well then here's
the thing no being bi it's like I think
you almost have to go all the way gay if
you're just being bi didn't anybody
could do that pick a lane
yeah or just at Lisa being bars kind of
like taking the easy way out I feel like
a little yeah cuz you just play both
sides yeah Oh Jaden Smith that little
twink though he's like full-blown I
don't know I haven't heard that but
maybe full-blown is an HIV term in the
90s
that shit's cured bro but the term ain't
there's whole bones all good no I mean
it's good but it's you know I'm not I'm
okay with being unblown you know why I
like to be full look then it looked well
shoutout to full-blown what are you
gonna be bro oh yeah I'm gonna be on
tour man I got some shows a new show
that are from Manchester or London
you're gonna you're up soon yep in
September and it's a new afternoon show
and you can just go to Theo van calm
slash tour and and get tickets to it go
see one of the best I'm talking about
feeling up myself oh I'll go see one of
the up-and-coming and hard-working
future best your dates Brendan I am in
Indy oops I'm in Cincinnati next week
next Friday Saturday at Cincinnati week
after I'm in Indy and then tickets for
Nashville and Portland just went on sale
thief at kake.com get you some dude
horses in the front horses in the front
horses in the back you know we could
have stopped at horses in the front why
not in the back - all right little na
style horses horses everywhere
[Music]